antes de que veamos la preparación de
alcoholes usando boro y duro de sodio
recordemos algunas de las otras maneras
de hacer alcoholes de las cuales
hablamos en vídeos anteriores por
ejemplo puedes hacer alcoholes de al que
no si puedes añadir el o h utilizando la
regla de mar
cof cof o puedes agregar el lo h de
acuerdo a la regla
en ti
cof cof esa es una manera de hacer
alcoholes pero también puedes hacerlos a
partir de alumnos de alquilo el proceso
puede ser tanto s n 1 como s n 2 y luego
de lo que aún no hemos hablado es cómo
preparar alcoholes de compuestos carbón
y lycos y hay diferentes maneras de
hacer eso
puedes utilizar oro y duro de sodio n
h 4 qué es lo que vamos a tratar en este
vídeo en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
hablar del uso de hidruro del litio y
aluminio l
l h 4 y también puedes utilizar un
órgano metálico como sería un reactivo
de guiñar
así que escribiré eso aquí abajo también
e incluso vamos a hablar de eso en el
siguiente vídeo para lo único que
tenemos tiempo en este vídeo es para el
boro y duro de sodio así que veamos la
reacción general para utilizar boro y
duro de sodio en la generación de un
alcohol puedes ver aquí en la izquierda
que empezamos tanto con un aldehído como
con una acetona tenemos ahí un aldehído
o una
zona
aquí tanto puede haber un hidrógeno
unido a tu carbón y lo como un grupo r
prima vamos a añadir poro hidruro de
sodio y luego vamos a agregar una fuente
de protones podría hacer casi cualquier
cosa por lo que h más parece funcionar y
vamos a formar un alcohol primario o uno
secundario dependiendo de nuestros
materiales iniciales esto va a ser un
alcohol primario o
un diario veamos el mecanismo para la
preparación de alcoholes usando poro
hidruro de sodio
empecemos con una acetona así que vamos
a empezar con una acetona por lo que
solo escribiremos la reacción
de esta manera
tengo mi carbón y lo pongo mis pares
libres de electrones y luego hago esto
una r prima para hacer nuestra acetona y
necesitamos también al boro y duro de
sodio así que continuemos dibujando su
estructura
n
más carga formal positiva y después
tenemos el boro unido a
cuatro hidrógenos de esta manera
y hay una carga formal de -1 en nuestro
coro por lo que lo ponemos ahí también
el mecanismo que mostraré está
simplificado el mecanismo completo es un
poco más complicado pero el que te
mostraré funciona por lo que utilicemos
sólo la versión simplificada bien lo
primero en lo que debes pensar es en
este carbón y lo de aquí este carbono
que tiene un doble enlace con el oxígeno
hay una diferencia en electrónica
tividad entre el carbono y el oxígeno
aquí este carbono y este oxígeno el
oxígeno es más electro negativo lo que
significa que esos enlaces los
electrones en el enlace doble entre el
carbono y el oxígeno van a estar más
cerca del oxígeno por lo tanto el
oxígeno tiene una carga parcial negativa
cierto por lo que se incrementa la
densidad electrónica a su alrededor
mientras tanto este carbono está
perdiendo algunos de los electrones que
lo rodean por
parcialmente positivo si el carbono es
parcialmente positivo es nuestro electro
filo quiere electrones y de donde
podemos obtener nuestros electrones
podemos obtener nuestros electrones de
aquí los dos electrones en este
hidrógeno van a moverse y atacar a este
carbono por lo que esa será la porción
núcleo física de nuestra molécula y eso
serían demasiados enlaces en un carbono
por lo que uno de estos este enlace pide
aquí va a pasarse al oxígeno así que se
añadirán dos electrones a él
continuamos dibujando los productos de
ese ataque núcleo físico entonces
tenemos r y luego r carbono y después r
prima por acá y este oxígeno de arriba
tenía dos pares de electrones libres y
acaba de tomar uno más para un total de
tres y eso le da una carga formal de
menos 1
y añadimos un hidrógeno así
continuamos y resaltamos algunos
electrones para que podamos ver a dónde
se fue todo estoy diciendo que este
hidrógeno
y los dos electrones en este enlace se
convirtieron en
este hidrógeno y estos dos electrones de
aquí realmente lo que estás haciendo es
usar al boro y duro de sodio como una
fuente de uniones y duró un año y duró
sería un hidrógeno con dos electrones
alrededor
y una carga formal negativa de -1
esa es la manera de pensar en estos
reactivos el litro por sí mismo no es el
mejor núcleo filo porque no es
suficientemente polariza bleu es un
átomo tan pequeño que no funciona muy
bien como un núcleo filo por sí mismo
esto por supuesto es nuestra versión
simplificada bien en el siguiente paso
de nuestro mecanismo tendremos algo de
química ácido base así que tenemos
protones flotando alrededor es cierto
por lo que añadimos h más a nuestra
solución y el par libre de electrones
toma el protón
y hemos terminado así que dibujemos el
producto
nuestro alcohol
y continuamos poniendo esos pares libres
de electrones
y sólo hay un hidrógeno unido a nuestro
carbono si empezamos con la acetona
vamos a terminar con un alcohol
secundario como en este caso bien
hagamos una reacción real empecemos con
barniz lina
la van y lina es una molécula que huele
bastante bien y si ver la estructura de
la van y lina hay un grupo funcional
adherido en nuestro anillo
también hay otros grupos funcionales así
que continuaré y pondré el resto de la
molécula de baní elena vamos a añadir
poro y duro de sodio en nuestro primer
paso vamos a añadir boro y duro de sodio
en nuestro primer paso
y luego una vez que eso haya reaccionado
vamos a añadir una fuente de protones
hcl funciona bastante bien para esta
reacción sólo diremos que utilizamos una
fuente de h más así cuando tratas de
saber el producto de una prueba ni
siquiera es necesario hacer ese
mecanismo simplificado puedes pretender
que el johnny duro va a actuar como un
núcleo filo aunque ya hemos dicho que no
necesariamente hace eso aquí tenemos
nuestro núcleo filo
y duro así que va a atacar este carbono
de aquí este es nuestro carbono
carbónico
así que será parcialmente positivo eso
va a mandar estos electrones a nuestro
oxígeno de esta manera
continuamos dibujando el intermedio para
esta reacción
así que tendremos nuestro anillo de
benceno
así
pondré en los otros grupos funcionales
por acá
los cuales no participan en la reacción
continuamos dibujando lo que tenemos
aquí teníamos un hidrógeno que ya estaba
unido a ese carbono acabamos de añadir
otro hidrógeno a ese carbono y luego
tenemos a un oxígeno ahí con tres pares
libres de electrones alrededor de él
dándole una carga formal de menos 1 así
que cuando añadimos nuestra fuente de
protones un par libre tomara ese protón
de allí para formar nuestro alcohol
continuaremos dibujando nuestro producto
justo aquí
una vez más tenemos un bache saliendo de
nuestro anillo y tenemos esta parte de
la molécula esta porción de éter por
aquí y luego tenemos un alcohol así esta
molécula ya que tiene una estructura
similar a la van y lina también tiene un
muy buen aroma es muy agradable por lo
que esta es una muy buena práctica de
laboratorio de química orgánica para
universitarios y clasificamos el tipo de
alcoholes que obtenemos podemos obtener
uno primario uno secundario o terciario
así que recuerda cómo hacer eso
identificas el carbono que está
directamente unido a lo h
ese es este carbono y observas a cuántos
carbonos está unido ese carbono ese
carbono está unido a un carbono más por
lo que este es un ejemplo de alcohol
primario
si empiezas con un aldehído si empiezas
con un aldehído como lo hicimos aquí
este es nuestro aldehído vas a terminar
con un alcohol primario como producto
hagamos otro esta vez hagamos un acetona
bien continuamos dibujando un acetona
aquí haremos un ciclo hexano na
aquí está nuestra acetona así y vamos a
añadir boro y duro de sodio así n
de h 4 y vamos a añadir metanol
y haremos esto en un paso una vez más
piensa en boro y duro de sodio como una
fuente de aniones y duro bien una vez
más aunque este no es técnicamente el
mecanismo
es nuestra versión simplificada así que
si estás haciendo un examen esta es la
manera más fácil de hacerlo
atacas ese carbono mueves estos
electrones a tu oxígeno tenemos a
nuestros productos intermedios por acá
continuamos dibujando eso tenemos el
ataque de lannion hidruro para formar un
nuevo enlace con lo que solía ser
nuestro carbono carbon el ico ahora este
oxígeno tiene tres pares libres de
electrones alrededor de él y una carga
formal de menos 1 va a tomar un protón
del metanol como su fuente de protones
esta vez y por lo tanto nuestro producto
final si es que vamos a dibujarlo voy a
dejar el hidrógeno
aquí
y verás la razón en un segundo y luego
tengo mi oh h
de esta manera por lo que formo
ciclohexano na como mi producto esta es
una reacción de reducción estamos
reduciendo la molécula para formar
nuestro alcohol así que tomemos los
reactivos y el producto de esta reacción
y asignemos algunos estados de oxidación
para poder ver como este es un ejemplo
de una reacción de reducción
voy a dibujar nuevamente nuestra acetona
iniciada aquí continuemos poniendo
algunos de los átomos esta vez
solo dibujaré otra vez la acetona
inicial de esta manera continuaré
dibujando el producto que obtuvimos
también muy bien pondré estos carbonos
aquí
y luego añadimos un hidrógeno de esta
manera y luego formamos nuestro alcohol
por aquí así así que continuamos
pensando en los estados de oxidación
cuando estamos asignando estados de
oxidación necesitamos continuar
dibujando
estos electrones aquí cierto déjame
continuar poniendo estos electrones en
estos enlaces de aquí así
bien ahora pensemos en como hicimos esto
en algunos de los vídeos anteriores ese
hecho pensar en electro negatividad y si
estoy pensando en los 4 electrones entre
el carbono y el oxígeno el oxígeno es
más electro negativo por lo que el
oxígeno va a tener todos esos electrones
continuamos de esta manera carbono
contra carbono peleándose estos dos
electrones tienen la misma electro
negatividad obviamente ya que son el
mismo elemento así que cada carbono
tendrá uno de esos electrones y lo mismo
pasa aquí
cuando asignamos nuestros estados de
oxidación decimos que es el número de
electrones de valencia que el carbono
tiene normalmente el cual por supuesto
es 4 y a eso le restamos el número de
electrones alrededor de él cuando
tomamos en cuenta la electro negatividad
la cual es 2
en este caso por lo que el estado de
oxidación de ese carbono es más 2
tenemos un estado de oxidación de más 2
a la izquierda ahora pensemos en lo de
la derecha continuamos poniendo nuestros
electrones cada enlace consiste de 2
electrones así que continuamos con el
hecho de que cada enlace consiste de 2
electrones aquí de esta manera y una vez
más pensamos en las diferencias de
electro negatividad nuevamente sabemos
que carbono contra carbono es un empate
por lo que podemos continuar de esta
manera y carbono contra oxígeno el
oxígeno es más electro negativo por lo
que va a tener estos electrones de aquí
pero carbono contra hidrógeno el carbono
es un poco más electro negativo así que
ahora el carbono tomara esos 2
electrones el carbono normalmente tiene
4 en este caso el carbono tiene 4
alrededor de él después tomamos en
cuenta la electro negatividad por lo que
el estado de oxidación de ese átomo de
carbono es
pensemos en qué pasó con el estado de
oxidación empezamos con un estado de
oxidación de más 2
y ese número fue reducido a un estado de
oxidación de 0 esta es una reacción de
reducción cierto esta es una red
acción
hay varias definiciones diferentes que
puedes usar puedes pensar en reducción
como una disminución en el estado de
oxidación o una reducción en el estado
de oxidación también puedes pensar en
ese carbono ganando electrones por lo
que tomo 2 electrones más y otra manera
de pensar en eso es como un carbono que
perdió un enlace al oxígeno aquí en la
izquierda el carbono tenía dos enlaces
al oxígeno aquí en la derecha el carbono
solo tiene un enlace con el oxígeno y
formó un enlace con hidrógeno aumentaron
el número de enlaces al hidrógeno
disminuyeron el número de enlaces al
oxígeno esta es otra manera de pensar en
esto como una reacción de reducción pero
asignando tus estados de oxidación es
probable la mejor manera de hacerlo en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver cómo
preparar alcoholes usando hidruro de
litio y aluminio el cual es muy similar
a usar el bromo hidruro de sodio